the fact that people keep asking you who
paid initially for the refurbishment of
the flat
and uh you haven't said i suppose the
question is
is all of this worth it i mean is the
refurbishment really that
good what's it look like tell the nation
what's wrong with john lewis
absolutely absolutely nothing if there's
one thing i object to in this whole
uh ferrargo of nonsense is that i have
anything i'd love john this and uh
but what i will say and what i will say
is i think that the
what do you love about it i think that
the what people
i want this government to to do is focus
on
their priorities and i know that uh
people uh
love these types of uh of issues and and
you've just asked the sort of uh
question that i i know westminster
people
are interested in quite properly uh sam
but actually
uh i think what uh people want our
government to do is get on
uh with the road map get on with taking
the country forward get on with the
fastest
uh vaccine rollout program in europe get
on with uh recruiting more
uh police officers i think we're now i
think we've got eight thousand seven
hundred seventy one
more which is we've over we've beaten
our target which was
uh six thousand uh by this stage
and uh bring crime down give people the
opportunity
of housing and get on with our agenda of
uniting
and leveling up across the country and
as i say by several orders of magnitude
i believe that's what people want the
government to be focusing
on right now prime minister thank you